the latest target in the season 4
manhunt
has confirmed a few suspicions that have
been discussed up until now
felix sokolov has been reunited with his
sister and he is thrilled to be able to
grow
and work together in a newly acquired
empire
but does she share the same intentions
russian businessman alexei sokolov is
the founder and ceo
of the hugely successful international
military equipment manufacturer
circle of concern alexei had a daughter
to an earlier relationship
that separated later for unknown reasons
he later married an american woman and
eventually they had his first
and only son felix as a family
they decided to relocate to his wife's
country of birth the united states
but left behind his daughter to keep the
family business taking along
her name was natalya circlova
alexi was hard on felix and had high
hopes and expectations that he forced
upon him
as soon as he graduated from school
felix was told by his father that he
must enlist with the navy
while on deployment his father died
under suspicious circumstances
and after a lengthy court battle felix's
mother was initially convicted of his
murder
when his tour was over he moved on to
study medicine at johns hopkins
university
it was during this time that he was
recruited by the strategic homeland
division
but regardless sometime after completing
his study he was approached and
recruited
by the black tusk
after her father's death and his
stepmother's conviction
natalia reached out to felix she went on
to fund her studies
and attempt to reunite with the brother
that she barely knew
when biden schaefer brought feylau on
board she met up with felix
during her induction
you were a good agent felix what made
you leave the division
family i get that you lose someone my
sister
the virus no rikers
i couldn't keep her safe budget cuts
well you'll never have that problem with
black dusk natalia will get us anything
we need
natalia my sister she runs this entire
operation
anything you need i can get it you don't
think it's weird she'd let you work in
the field
it's not the safest place for a kid like
you you've read my profile you know i've
served before
it's why the division recruited me well
that and i'm sure they got a family
discount on those knee pads you were
wearing when
schaefer brought you in
it's unclear with the natalya's name and
involvement with the black tusk
was a surprise to fey or not but she
didn't seem overly convinced that
natalya's intentions towards felix
were purely about tight family bonds
you asking the other candidates this
much about their families only when it's
relevant
so what else do you want to know how
close are you with your sister
not as close as i'd like it's hard she
grew up in russia i didn't really get to
know her until after our father died
that was what six or seven years ago six
what does it matter nothing just that's
around the same time she started black
task
so oh nothing i'm just thinking out loud
it's interesting that your father dies
she reconnects or connects with you
she inherits the company and builds this
pmc
it just seems like
never mind i've seen conspiracies where
they probably don't exist
my sister loves me i'm sure she does
when we lost her father she was allowed
to come from russia for the funeral it's
not that hard to understand
that in that moment she was there to
help me she put me through school
she got me this job she saw how agents
were dying and she sacrificed her men
to bring me in and protect me you don't
do that if you don't care about someone
felix wasn't having a bar of it he
refused to believe that natalia's help
was anything but family helping one
another
she offered him a role in the black tusk
after seeing how out of the
depth the division was she rescued him
from what was looking like
certain death
before the main operation faye talks to
felix about escorting your vip
castrol get your team ready got an
assignment nothing too big
just need you to escort a vip
babysitting duty
seriously don't you have some grunts who
can do this trust me this escort is too
important to leave to a rookie
well now you've got my attention
given what we know about the black tusk
at this stage and who remains in their
ranks
it's likely that this target is
president ellis or someone of equally
high importance to them
so they needed the right person for the
job
leading up to the operation felix
discusses strategy with viper
you ready for this absolutely you don't
mind not knowing who the target is
i trust faye and frankly she's right
we've had too many leaks she's smart to
keep this one close to the best
do you know who the target is i've got
my suspicions
but i'm not going to speculate i think
it's kelso
okay sparky don't strain that big brain
of yours
being young and eager felix is keen to
get started on the op
but expresses confusion around the lack
of intel
viper trusts fey and understands the
reasons behind the secrecy
unwilling to rock the boat felix accepts
this and continues with his preparation
when instructed to do so he set forth
executing his part in the operation
taking his band of btsu he started
capturing locations of interest
in the northeastern districts of
washington dc
multiple sites were captured in downtown
east federal triangle
and judiciary square however the
division were hot on his tail
and were quickly able to put a stop to
his advancements
after taking back these sites they were
able to find his location
well phoenix put up a somewhat
unorthodox assault
the division was eventually able to push
him back taking down his btsu guard
and eventually eliminating him in the
process
felix's manhunt confirms the suspicions
around natalya's involvement with the
black tusk
in fact as it turns out she's the
founder of the organization
this happened shortly after her father's
death when she inherited control of his
empire
the circumstances around her father's
death seem very suspicious
on one hand maybe natalia's american
stepmother did murder him
and this whole attack on the united
states is her way of enacting revenge
or maybe it was her who took him down
framing it on his wife
being somewhat separated from her
father's new family and not having the
tight connection that they may have once
had
she may have been presented with an
opportunity that required her to step up
and take control natalya has referred to
having business partners a couple of
times
and from the very start we've known that
the black tusk has deep ties
to people within the u.s government
perhaps she was approached
before assembling the black tusk and
before she could act on anything
she would need to remove the one small
obstacle in her path
her boss and father alexei sokolov
but where does felix come in with all of
this
in my opinion she has absolutely no
emotional bonds to him
he has simply been a convenient
distraction for authorities around
alexis death
also through caring for him paying his
way through college pulling him away
from the dangerously undermanned
and collapsing shd and then giving him a
position within the black tusk ranks
she has been granted an extremely loyal
soldier for a personal army
felix is a smart kid but he's young and
naive he is proud of finally being a
part of his sister's life
and she knows this felix is so smitten
by natalya's presence and generosity
plus the chance to reunite their family
that he has clouded any potential
warning signs
that could point to anything else
one thing is for certain though faye
doesn't seem overly convinced of
natalie's intentions
and now that barton is somewhat out of
the picture i'm sure we'll be seeing
clashes between these two
in the coming days
before i go please remember that there
are a number of us who choose not to
keep up to date with the story leaks
so try and refrain from publishing any
spoilers in the comments
otherwise i hope you've enjoyed this
video and i'll catch you in the next one
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
will you be there